hey guys how's it going so as promised
in my previous video I was going to
FaceTime and show you guys some of the
text messages that you guys have
basically destroyed you to my iPad on so
if you have no idea what I'm talking
about I just posted a video where I
talked about launching my first-ever
sticker pack on iMessage give iOS 10 you
can download them I just mean stickers
calm is the link that will take you
directly to it you can click in the
description also if you don't feel like
typing but I said that I was going to
FaceTime some of you guys and also
highlight some of the messages that I
have received and I've got over 10,000
messages and I'm not sure how to really
go about this because that's gonna be
impossible to respond to all of them but
even this morning some of you guys
actually were in actual shock that I was
responding back to Mew didn't believe it
was me so I was sending some selfies as
proof so I think the only way that a
more Wow 694 Meg's of messages so that's
basically you guys sabirah messages so I
think the only way that these messages
will ever stop receiving on this iPad is
if I get a hundred and five gigs of them
you want to send me a message you can
use I just seen stickers at gmail.com
I'm trying as hard as I can to respond
to people but here's one look at the
look at all these cute little stickers
ah I love this one of your dog Maddy so
cute I'm really hoping I can meet you
I'm traveling to Maui for the sixth
sixth time on February
oh my goodness I'm nervous hello oh my
god hold on I can't hear you can you
hear me yeah oh my goodness hold on I
think I have my sound turned off there's
so much stuff going on am I on my iPad
right now guys I'm doing my first call
say hello well thank you so much for
being my first call tell your friend
that I said hello yes
we'll have a good day I love you
yay oh my goodness
holy moly this is crazy
it wasn't letting me record the audio on
here I gotta figure some things out
first
oh okay so I've tried several things to
be able to capture from my iPad so I'm
gonna have to figure that out but I did
FaceTime a few of you guys and I'm
looking forward to doing it again but I
think we might have a problem cuz my
iPad is definitely not doing well so I'm
just gonna go through and check out some
of your text that you guys have sent I'm
gonna send you some stickers I'm gonna
give you up a kiss and the answer that
question with a controller oh my
goodness look I love you so much and you
might get to see this text I see it I
see it oh my gosh and we have a picture
together this is incredible I especially
love when you guys send me the pictures
of us previously meeting because then it
actually puts a face to a message hi
hello this is Justine I'm setting you
it's actually my first audio message so
hi hope you're having a great party bye
whoa whoa I can't even read what you
said this is so much fun we were
youtuber for like four four years
holy moly five years oh my god I can't
even read I'm gonna send them a photo
cheers thank you I'm watching her three
years what a great time I'm having I'm
having the time of my life
I'm sending iMessage love ray and dog
I'm not sure hi thanks so much for
downloading the stickers you're the best
for telling us because not it's not
right oh shoot I'm telling Siri to write
this to you and and now it's not working
and everything is just a mess
holy moly this is so great I'm having
the best time
okay let's do a few more oh thank you so
much I'm so glad you love the stickers
you're the best exclamation point
okay okay okay just one more I'm pretty
much gonna be doing this all weekend
until my iPad basically breaks so that's
gonna be kind of the plan here for this
weekend if you guys do get the stickers
let me know what you think of them also
feel free to tweet me pictures of them
because I'm also always on Twitter it's
also really fun to spam your friends
with them because some people don't know
how the stickers work so they get super
confused hopefully I can figure out the
FaceTime thing for the next video but
until then I did get a chance to chat to
a few of you so thank you so much for
answering looks on your guys's faces
when I actually do call it's incredible
you're like ahhh and then I'm just like
I thinking in the next video hope you
guys have a lovely weekend thanks again
if you do want the stickers I just seen
stickers calm link in the description
and be sure to email me iMessage me
don't email because I'm not gonna check
the email I just need stickers at
gmail.com okay guys have a good weekend
bye
[Music]